GOOD MORNING.
WE'LL GET STARTED AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
WELCOME TO WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE AGENDA TO.
TUESDAY JUNE TWELFTH TWELFTH.
.
ONE ANNOUNCEMENT TO MAKE S. B.
FIVE EIGHTEEN IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND THE.
I THINK THAT'S IT FOR.
WE HAVE EIGHT OKAY SO ONE WEEK
OF.
CALL THE ROLL SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY.
SCORE.
EDUARDO GARCIA AS A.
GALLAGHER. BIGELOW.
CARILLO.
CHOI HERE.
CHIU HERE.
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA.
HARPER PRESENT.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
MATHIS
RUBIO.
SALAS.
WOULD QUORUM ALREADY THINK IT
WAS
FRIDAY SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY.
LEARNING.
MAURY.
BUT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS SENATE
BILL FOUR NINE FIVE WILL GIVE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE ABILITY TO GRANT AN
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT. FOR THE
BLUNT NOSED LEOPARD LIZARD IN.
ORDER TO.
MENTIONS THAT.
DOGGONE SHARED SHOOTS UP TO YOU.
YEAH.
THERE'S A MOTION WE NEED THIS
WELL REALLY BACK.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR US SO YOU
WITNESSES TO ABSOLUTELY WITH ME
I HAVE JESSIE SNYDER WITH SELF
HELP ENTERPRISES AND SHERRY
HUNTER AND DENISE QATAR.
RESIDENTS OF BALANCE OR.
THE MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
I WE DO INDEED AS A SENATOR SAID
NEED THIS WELL REAL BAD AND THEY
BLUNT NOSED LEOPARD LIZARD TO
THE FULLY PROTECTED SPECIES.
WHICH MEANS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE HAS NO
DISCRETION WHATSOEVER TO WORK
WITH US ON AN INCIDENTAL TAKE
PERMIT. THE WELL SITE WE'VE
SELECTED WHICH WILL DELIVER GOOD
WATER TO THE COMMUNITY OF
ALLENSWORTH IS. AYE INHABITED BY
MANY MANY MANY BLUNTNOSE LEOPARD
LIZARDS AND WHICH MEANS WE CAN'T
AVOID THEM AND BUT WE CAN MAKE
GOOD PLANS TO MITIGATE THE ANY
IMPACT THAT WE MIGHT HAVE. AND
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW FISH IN MY LIFE TO WORK
WITH US TO DO SO THANK YOU.
Q.
SPEAKER.
MY NAME IS SHERRY HUNTER I'M
PRESIDENT OF OUT OF SORTS
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT
WHICH.
WE DELIVER WATER TO THE
COMMUNITY. AND WATER IS ALWAYS
VAN.
BIG ISSUE AND ALLEN'S OR.
SELF HELP HELPED US GET FUNDING
TO.
AND FIND AT AREA WHERE WE COULD
FIND GOOD DRINKING WATER BUT OF
COURSE.
WE RAN INTO THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
SITUATION WHERE WE HAD TO GET A
PASS FROM THEM IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO DO. DID THE NEW WELL AND
OF COURSE OUT OF IT IS TRYING TO
GROW BUT WATER IS ALWAYS THE
ISSUE WATER HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
ISSUE AND ALLENSWORTH.
HAVE BEEN GOOD DRINK AND WATER.
AND.
*.
TODAY THERE THE BILL FOR NINETY
FIVE IS ABLE TO BE PASSED TO
HELP US TO GROW AND PROSPER WIG
GOOD CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DENISE COULD ARE I'M
ALSO A RESIDENT OF ALLENSWORTH
AND.
AS BOTH OF THE LADIES HAVE
STATED THERE'S DEFINITELY GOT
DIRE NEED FOR.
THIS LEGISLATION TO GO FORTH
FOR THE COMMUNITY OF ALLAH'S
WORD. HISTORICALLY WE'VE HAD A
ARSENIC PROBLEM.
WITHOUT WATER WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE HAD TO DO REAL WELLS THREE
MILES EAST OF OUR COMMUNITY. AND
IN SO DOING NOW WHERE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IN OF THE SITE. WE'RE
STILL RUNNING INTO PROBLEMS AND
THIS TIME IT JUST HAPPENS TO BE
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES THE
LEOPARD LIZARD. AND WE ARE.
YOU KNOW COMING BEFORE YOU TODAY
IN HOPES THAT YOU WILL
UNDERSTAND OUR CRISIS WITH OUR
WATER SITUATION AND THAT WE WILL
CONSIDER.
GIVEN US THE LEGISLATURE WAVING
THE REQUIREMENT FOR A FOR THIS
SITUATION SO WE CAN HAVE. A
WHALE FOR WE CAN HAVE QUALITY
DRINKING WATER AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
STATE'S POLICY THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO DRINKING
WATER.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
REQUESTING NOW AND THE NEED FOR
THIS LEGISLATION PASSED WILL
ENABLE US TO. HOPEFULLY.
HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
TULARE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THE BOARD IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AS WE
BELIEVE THAT WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO ESTABLISH
MEDICATION MEASURES. WHILE I'M
OPENING UP SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR ALLENSWORTH THANK YOU.
DENNIS HUTS IN THE RESIDENT OF
ALLENSWORTH AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THIS.
ISSUE.
BOB DOLE KADAR.
A RESIDENT OF THE COMMUNITY AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
WELL.
I'M CLICK ADARA A I'M A RESIDENT
OF THE COMMUNITY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND I AM KILEY DAY KATARA IT A
RESIDENTS OF THE COMMUNITY OF
ALLENSWORTH.
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF.
THE BILL ALSO THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEE NO ONE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MANY MEMBERS.
OKAY WOULD LIKE BECAUSE.
WE DO HAVE A QUESTION.
GRAY BILL LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR.
I ASK DRIVE OUT THANK YOU
ALRIGHT.
IT HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
TO SOME APPROPRIATIONS I'M
SECRETARY.
THE TERM MOTION.
SECOND MAKE A MOTION AT.
THANK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER AYE AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU AYE WHICH
YOU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA
AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SALAS. SALAS I WOULD. WOULD I.
FOURTEEN.
OKAY WOULDN'T THAT OPUS JEFF
WITH PROFESSORS ONLY ONE PERSON
MISSING.
HELLO I'M LEAVE THAT OPEN THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH EFFECT. GIVE.
LAKE
.
RIGHT THEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THAT MEMBERS.
I AS MOST OF YOU PROBABLY
REMEMBER LAST YEAR I PRESENTED A
BILL TO THIS COMMITTEE. THAT
WOULD HAVE BANNED SMOKING AT
STATE PARKS AND BEACHES.
UNFORTUNATELY AFTER PASSING THE
LEGISLATURE AND THIS COMMITTEE
WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
.
SO I'D A TAKEN THAT BILL ITS
THAT WITH TO SUBJECT AREAS AND I
SPLIT IT AND THAT IN THE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES ONE DEALING
WITH THAT SMOKING ITS STATE
PARKS WHICH IS THIS BILL.
AND THE OTHER ONE DEALING WITH A
SMOKING ON STATE BEACHES.
AT THEIR SOME CHANGES IN THIS
BILL FROM WHAT YOU HEARD BEFORE
IT LOWERS THE FINES FROM A
HUNDRED DOLLARS DOWN TO TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS TO DEAL WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S.
VETO MESSAGE.
.
AND AS YOU SEE IN THE BILL IT IT
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND REC TO DESIGNATE
AREAS WITHIN UNITS OF THE STATE
PARKS SYSTEM IS EXEMPT FROM THE
SMOKING PROHIBITION.
THAT MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF ITS AND
RECOGNIZE UP MICHAEL AUTHOR WHO
HAS A SIMILAR BILL ON THE ISSUE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND ASK
FOR YOUR I THANK YOU.
WINDS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT PLEASED TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
I HAVEN'T DEPORTING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
DOUG HOUSTON REPRESENTED EAST
BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
THE CALIFORNIA PARK RECREATION
SOCIETY BOTH IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SO LEASE SEAN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND.
NOTHING GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
KELLY BROKE SOME BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE. I'M COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA FOR NOW REPRESENTING
THE SIXTY ONE ON PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE IN
SUPPORT.
THE MONEY JUST MULLIN FOR THE
KINGS HE'S LOPPING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS ON BEHALF THE MARCH
OF DIMES AND SUPPORT.
CAN'T DO BURKE WITH THE HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
BECAUSE JONES A CIRCLE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
ALRIGHT HER ANNUAL WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SAYING. NO
ONE THERE'S MOTIONS SECT UP WE
HAVE WHAT I PARTED ME I CAN MAKE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
TOBACCO HARM REDUCTION JUST
REALLY QUICKLY REMAIN
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE I AM.
BECAUSE E. CIGARETTES ARE NINETY
FIVE PERCENT LESS HARMFUL THAN
CIGARETTES WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AID AND HARM REDUCTION IN
HELPING PEOPLE QUIT SO WE'D ASK
THAT THEY BE REMOVED THANK YOU.
YOU.
AND WHERE ELSE.
SEE NO ONE DATA.
MEMBERS IT TOO MANY QUESTIONS
THOMAS. YEAH.
DOT DR YEAH OUT I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT HIS PARTNER WHO
APPEAR OWES.
.
I.
HAVE DONE NAM NET EXTENSIVE.
.
STUDIO OR INDIA SECONDARY.
FOR. A SMALL FOR A HEALTHY
IMPACT.
YEAH ABOUT THE HOW TO SAY.
A. MY NINE YEARS AGO IN THE CITY
OF IRVINE. AND THE. A MY INTERNS
ARE AT THAT TIME DID THE STUDY.
OF THE YEAR NEGATIVELY HAS THE
IMPACT OF THE SECOND OF SMOKING.
IS ARE SOMETIMES EVEN MORE
DETRIMENTAL THAN DIE IF AND A
SMOKER HIMSELF WELL. AND THEN
ALSO AS A NON SMOKER A HOW MANY
TIMES.
POWERED.
PEOPLE WANT NON SMOKING.
A.
THEIR RIGHTS ARE INFRINGED I
KNOW THIS IS VARIAS SENSITIVITY
ISSUE. THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO A SMOKE.
OH YES I.
UNDERSTAND THAT THE HIGHWAY AS
STRONG AS SO.
THAT THE SMOKE CAN BE CONFINED
THAT WOULD NOT IMPACT.
TEACH MATH PEOPLE US AROUND THE.
A.
BUT THAT DOES FAR.
BUT. IN MOST CASES.
THE SMOKER WAS JUST A FLOOR
ANYWHERE THAT THE WIND BLOW
SOUTH. AND THE PEOPLE ARE AROUND
THE SMOKER.
A WOODED BE. IN VIOLENT TORTILLA
WHAT IN HELL.
AND THEN THAT IMPACT ON OUR EARS
ARE VERY DETRIMENTAL. PLEA IN
GENERAL AS WELL AS SELF FOR THE
PEOPLE. WHO ARE MAYBE A LOGIC
TO?
SUCH A SMOKE SO I THINK THAT
THE SYSTEM MORE POP UP. UP
PUBLIC.
HEALTHY ISSUE AND THEN I THINK
THIS BILL WILL HELP.
A IN A GENERAL. A HOPEFUL DOT
RIGHT SELF NON A SMOKER SIR SO.
A. IT IS SO OF THE AREA.
.
PERSONALIZED. A.
THE ISSUE OF THE SMOKE WAS IN
NON SMOKERS. UP BUT DOT IN ANY
COMMUNITY ARE YOU MAY RUN INTO A
SIMILAR ISSUE SIR BUT THE IN THE
CITY OF IRVINE. A WE DEBATED
THIS SO A LOTTA AND THE.
COMPANIES. MOSTLY IRVINE COMPANY
OWNS A MAJORITY OF THE.
COMMERCIAL LAND RATHER THAN.
BATTING THE SMOKING.
AND THE SCHOOL WAS SO.
WE CHOSE TO CITY OF IRVINE AYE
TO COLLABORATE WITH YEAR BILL AT
THE BUILDING OWNERS IN THE
SHOPPING AT THE OWNERS.
THEY PUT DE UP VERY FRIENDLY
SIGH.
NON SMOKING ENVIRONMENT.
A AND THE PEOPLE ROUTE I'M OF
THAT.
AND THEY SELECT A NO SMOKING
EXTERNAL SMOKING ENVIRONMENT.
AND W. WE'VE BEEN A VERY
SUCCESSFUL SO ALL THE PARKS.
THAT THE IN THE CITY OF IRVINE
ONE THIRD OF THE COMMUNITY
ERISA.
A MADE UP OF OPEN SPACE AND
PARKS ARE.
A AND DONE THE SHOPPING CENTERS.
ON.
NOT QUITE HUNDRED PERCENT I SEE
SECRET BUT SIR IN THE IN IN THE
PARKS EVEN THOUGH WE PREVENTED
IN THE PARKS. IS SMOKING IS A
BAND. BUT THE THEY'RE ARE SOME
IN A BAD THAT PERSISTENCE DRIVE
TO VIOLATE THE. BUT I THINK THAT
THIS IS OUR TOP PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES ARE BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
DISTRIBUTORS. NATURE.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS. MISTER
HARPER.
I MAY HAVE MISSED HEARD IN YOUR
INTRODUCTION ON.
I'M HELPING TO TRY TO CLARIFY.
THE RELATIONSHIP OF THE TWO
BILLS.
THE BACKGROUND I HAVE IS THAT
THIS BILL S. B. THREE.
.
EIGHT I THIRTY FIVE IS INCLUSIVE
OF THE STATE BILLS.
THE FIRST ONE AND INCLUDES THE
STATE BEACHES OR EXCLUDES THE
STATE BEACHES LEAVING IT FOR THE
SECOND ONE PLEASE CLEAR. THROUGH
THROUGH THE CHAIR AT THIS
MEASURE DEALS WITH STATE PARKS
ONLY.
THE NEXT MEASURE WILL DEAL WITH
BEACHES.
SO ART ART STATE BEACHES IN
CLOSE HAVE A LOT IN MY DISTRICT
HUNTINGTON STATE BEACH BALLS
CHECK A STATEMENT WHICH. I IS
WELL AS CRYSTAL CHO STATE BEACH
ARE ALL UNDER THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM
I'D IS OUR AND IT IS THIS
EXCLUSIVE OR INCLUSIVE OF THE
BEACHES IN THE STATE PARKS.
IN BOTH CASES WE GIVE
AUTHORIZATION TO THE TO THE
DIRECTOR OF PARKS AND REC.
TO PROVIDE SMOKING AREAS TO DEAL
WITH SIGNAGE SO THAT THE
AUTHORITY ALL ULTIMATELY.
AND HOW IT'S IMPLEMENTED WILL BE
WITH STATE PARKS.
BECAUSE AS YOU INDICATE BEACHES
ARE UNDER PARKS THEM ARE. THIS
BILL THAT DEALS WITH THE SMOKING
BAN ON STATE.
I.
PARKS.
PARK LAND.
CHINA IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING AND
I LOOK FOR CLARIFICATION IF
THERE IS ONE ITS EXCLUSIVE OF
BEACHES.
THAT'S WHY I. EIGHT THIRTY SIX
DEAL SPECIFICALLY WITH PEACHES
NOW THERE'S A CLARIFICATION I'M
I'M OPENED IT TO THAT WORK
THERE'S A CONCERN ABOUT IT. ON
YOUR BEHALF IT MAYBE I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IT BETTER.
YEAH I THINK I'M JUST TRYING TO
LOOK FOR FOR SOME ACCURACY HERE
BECAUSE I'M I'M GETTING SOME
CONFLICTING INFORMATION OF
WHETHER IT'S INCLUSIVE OR
EXCLUSIVE STATE BEACH.
THE OTHER STAFF HAVE.
WELL I THINK THE TERM TO THE
STAFF HERE WHAT WE ARE STANDING
IS THAT THE FIRST BILL INCLUDES
EVERYTHING. THE SECOND THOSE
SPECIFIC THE STATE THAT WHAT I
HAD TO TO BEACHES EXCUSE ME
THAT'S THAT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
HERE SO.
THE HELP IT IS OBVIOUS HARPER
YES.
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEN KNOWN WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THIS.
FRIEDMAN A SECOND FIGHT ME ON
BEFORE I TOOK THE GAVEL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
CHOI AYE AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
CHU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER
THOUGH HARPER NO. KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS NO MATHIS NO RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD I WOULD I.
THREE.
SO THAT MOTION PASSES MISTER
GLAZER HARM.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT UP OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON. PLEASE
PER SE SECOND OF THANKS OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL. BY ISRAEL IN
RESPONSE THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE THAT THE CALLED OUT THAT
BEACHES IN PARTICULAR AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE DIVIDED THE QUESTION
SO THAT. THOSE WHO MIGHT HAVE A
CONCERN HER GREATER SUPPORT FOR
THE ISSUE OF CPAS BEACHES AND
SPECIFIC WOULD HAVE THAT CHANCE
ON THIS BILL. FOR THAT ASTEROID
BELT.
VERY MUCH A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER HARPER.
I'VE EXPRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES UP BEFORE AND NOT IN
PREVIOUS BLLS. ON.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE'S
TWO HARMS THAT ARE EXPRESSED HER
TO AREAS TO SEE AGAINST THAT ARE
EXPRESSED OF ONE IS THE LITTER
SIDE.
OF WHICH I YOU CAN MAKE CASE IN
TERMS OF FILTERS OF CIGARETTES
UP BUT IN TERMS OF CIGARS YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT FILTER ISSUE AND
SO. I THAT I THINK IS SOMETHING
THAT. I THINK MAY BE PROBLEMATIC
IN TERMS OF DATA KIND OF AN
ISSUE ALSO IN TERMS OF.
VAPING PRODUCTS AND SUCH LIKE
THAT BUT THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
AYE DOCUMENTATION OR SHOWING
THAT THAT'S A CONTRIBUTOR ON A
LETTER SITE PEOPLE SEEM TO WANT
TO KEEP THEIR.
PRODUCT IN TERMS OF.
OF THOSE HAVE VAPING PRODUCTS
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S ENSURE WHY
DOES HER INCLUDE NAFTA
SECONDHAND SMOKE SIDE.
THE DIFFERENCE YOU HAVE VERSES
MAYBE SOME INLAND PARK AREAS IS
THAT SMOKING IS AT THE BEACH
TYPICALLY IS VERY DISPERSED
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
WEATHER AT THE BEACH THERE'S
TYPICALLY EITHER AN OCEAN
BREEZE.
OR HEAVY OF.
HEAVY OCEAN WINDS UP ONE OF THE
OTHER VERY MUCH DISPERSES
I ANY KIND OF A SMOKER
SECONDHAND SMOKE SECTOR. I KNOW
ONLY THAT BUT THERE'S PLENTY OF
ROOM AT THE BEACH.
IN WHICH A PEOPLE CAN NOW I GO
TO AN AREA WHERE THERE IS
SMOKING WHERE THERE'S NOT
SMOKING EXCEPT FOR.
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH SPACE
ODD THAT THAT IS INDEED
AVAILABLE AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT PEOPLE CAN.
COEXIST ARE ON A BEACH BECAUSE
THERECERTAINLY IS ROOM
ESPECIALLY WITH THE A
DISBURSEMENT SMOKE.
I AND LASTLY I DON'T SEE THE
HARM IN SOMEBODY SMOKING A CIGAR
NEXT TO A BEACH BONFIRE RING.
THE ISSUE IS SMOKE.
SMOKE IS ALREADY THERE WITH THE
UPBEAT BONFIRE AYE IN SO WHAT TO
PROHIBIT.
PEOPLE'S ENJOYMENT OF THAT I
THINK IS.
IT IS IT.
PRETTY WERE.
SO I'LL BE VOTING AGAINST.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
THIS THIS ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD JUST
COMMENT.
.
THAT WE ARE IN OUR TOBACCO
REGULATION OUR TOBACCO BILLS ON
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN I CAN'T REMEMBER EXACTLY
WHEN.
WE EXCEED BAXI DEFINE VAPING.
WE'RE TREATING VAPING LIKE
TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND THAT'S WHY
I BELIEVE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
STATE LAW THAT'S WHY THAT IS
INCLUDED THERE. AND.
HAVE SAYS SOMEONE HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME ADVOCATE AGAINST A
SMOKING AND WHO'S BEEN AROUND MY
PARKS AND PICKED UP HUNDREDS OF
CIGARETTE* PRIOR TO US
BANNING SMOKING IN OUR PARKS.
I TIE DO THEY DISAGREE THAT ON
CIGARS ARE SOMEHOW LESS
OFFENSIVE THEY'RE JUST BIGGER.
AND NASTIER THINGS IN MY
OPINION SITTING ON BEACHES AND%
I'D LIKE TO SEE THEM GO AWAY AS
WELL SO I'M FROM IN IN SUPPORT
OF YOUR BILL ON MISTER GLAZER
ADAM DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS THAT MIGHT MAKE MY
CLOSING COMMENTS WOULD BE THAT.
OF COURSE I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
LETTER AS I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
FORCE FIRES THAT COME AS RESULTS
OF.
SMOKING BUT THAT THE PRIMARY
FOCUS IS IN THE AREA HEALTH
EFFECTS OF SECONDHAND SMOKE.
AND BEING CONSISTENT WITH STATE
LAWS AND.
.
I EIGHT WE PROVIDE SOME ELEMENT
OF FLEXIBILITY TO THE DIRECTOR
OF PARKS AND REC TEAMS SET ASIDE
DESIGNATED SMOKING AREAS AND.
THEY WISH TO DO IT TO WEAR A
BONFIRE IS BEING CONDUCTED THAT
THAT PERSON WOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO. SMOKE THERE BUT
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE BEEN ON
OUR BEACHES AND I'M SURE MANY OF
YOU IF NOT ALL OF YOU HAVE.
.
IRRESPECTIVE OF SOME BREEZES
THAT MIGHT BE BLOWING THAT DAY.
I THOUGHT THE SECOND AT HAND A
IMPACTS OF SMOKING IS VERY
PREVALENT.
I AND I THINK THAT ALL OF US
HAVE PROBABLY EXPERIENCE THAT IN
WHICH IS WHY.
THIS BILL IS SO VALUABLE TO OUR
GOOD HEALTH OF OUR CITIZENRY
WITHOUT ASTRONAUT VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GLAZIER WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS
FRIEDMAN A SECOND BY MISS RUBIO
MALWARE. CLUBS SORRY.
THEN FOOT THAT MISS RUBIO WAS
THE MOTION IS FRIEDMAN WAS THE
SECOND EACH YEAR. WILL CALL THE
TIE.
PLEASE MEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS DUE TO
PASS INTO THE PREPARATIONS THANK
YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CARILLO.
CARILLO I.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
GENERAL AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER NO.
FOR NO KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
MATHIS NO RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS NO WOULD I WOULD I THANK
YOU.
NINE TO FOUR
SO THAT MOTION PASSES AS WELL
NINETY FOUR WOULD LEAVE THE ROLL
UP AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
THINK MISTER GLAZER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALL.
SO WE DO HAVE AN ITEM. THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS.
DO WE HAVE WE HAD A WE HAVE MUCH
TO HERE'S I'M SORRY DIDN'T. OF
SO EXCITED BY MISTER SALAS IS
MOTION THAT IT MISSED THE
SECOND.
SECOND ONLY GOOD AS WE HAVE
SECOND. OH I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
THIS IS SO IT'S IT'S SO
CONFUSING APPEAR.
SO WE HAVE COMPOSED AND BY MR
SALAS WITH CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS ITEM A IS A BILL IS S.
B. FIVE EIGHTEEN.
RIGHT YEAH I DID.
.
MOTION BY MISTER SALAS WILL CALL
THE SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
KOREA AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE LEVINE AYE
AYE LEVINE AYE MATHIS. MET
MATHIS AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
SALAS.
SO SALAS I WOULD I WOULD I.
SO THAT IS SET TO SECULAR PAST
THIRTEEN OH WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
THAT CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BUT
I BELIEVE IS VERY.
WHAT WOULD REDUCE?
HANG ON.
OKAY
SO WE WILL.
WE WILL HOLD THE ROPE ROLE OPEN
WILL RECESS FOR TEN MINUTES WE
HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS
AT A TEN O'CLOCK AND MR GARCIA
WILL BE BACK.
OKAY.
WE'LL TAKE ON BECAUSE SHE
ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY EGGMAN SECRETARY PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
S. BEFORE NINETY FIVE CARILLO.
CARILLO I.
SP EIGHT THIRTY FIVE SALAS.
SALAS NO.
BUT FORGET THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL STAND IN RECESS FOR A
FEW MINUTES AND.
WE HAVE SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS
THANK YOU.
ENTERTAINMENT I KNOW.
NO NO NO.
CARILLO.
NUMBER.
JERRY.
SO GUNMAN.
WHILE THE PEOPLE WE DON'T KNOW
THAT HOMEOWNER GRANT.
.
JOHN BACK THERE STANDING IN THE
WAY WHO.
BY THE DOOR MUSKIES HANDED.
REMEMBER FOR THE
.
YEAH BUT